[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANOJ GUNTI: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to today's webcast
on intelligence insights
into API security.
My name is Manoj Gunti, and
I'm the product marketing
manager for Apigee at Google.
Before we begin the
webcast, I wanted
to take this couple
of minutes to cover
some housekeeping items.
What you see on
your slide should
resemble the webcast console,
and at the bottom left corner,
you will see a Q&A console where
you can post your questions.
Please note that you
don't have to wait
until the end of this webcast
to post your questions.
Please feel free to post them
at any time during the webcast,
and we will take
five to 10 minutes
at the end of the webcast
to go through them.
Next to the Q&A console
is the Resources section.
I will be making a
lot of references
to some of the resources
during this webcast,
and links to all
of those resources
will be available in
the Resources console
and for your reference.
So let's get started.
We will begin this
webcast by talking
a little bit about
the evolution of APIs
and how APIs have evolved
from being agents of access
to powering digital
transformation efforts
for several enterprises.
And we will learn
what this means
for operations teams in terms
of added pressure and some
of the challenges.
And we will be
introducing you today
to Apigee's brand new feature
called API security reporting.
We will learn about the key
components of this feature,
and we will also do a deep dive
demo into the functionality.
So Apigee has been traveling
with several customers
along their digital journey,
and all [INAUDIBLE] of time,
we have seen APIs evolving their
role within our enterprise IT
systems.
If we take some of our
customers, for example Equifax,
they have significantly
accelerated the time
to market of the new
products and services
by leveraging APIs
and API programs.
Their partner onboarding
time has significantly
reduced the defective
use of API programs.
And several companies
have built vast ecosystems
of developers and partners
using the API programs.
Ticketmaster, for example, is
today selling tickets not only
through their own
portal, but also they
are leveraging their partners
using API to sell their tickets
and improve the
overall fan experience.
And digital companies,
for example AccuWeather,
who has been a
customer of Apigee
for a long period of
time, has actually
opened up a new revenue
stream using APIs.
Today they are exposing key
weather data through APIs
to external developers, not
only through a developer portal,
but also through third
party marketplaces.
And they are also making those
APIs available for businesses
to embed them into their
business applications.
And all of this is happening
through API programs,
and this has helped them unlock
new revenue streams and open up
new markets.
So as APIs are
powering innovation
across these segments, what does
this mean for operations teams?
As you continue to follow your
business critical applications
and services with APIs, there
is an increasing pressure
on operations teams to
stay on top of that,
especially from a
security perspective.
So some of the challenges
that they face today
are to gain complete visibility
into the security attributes
of the APIs, to ensure
that whatever developers
are building are compliant with
the industry and organization's
compliance requirements.
They also want to make sure that
whenever there is an incident,
they want to know
about this incident,
even if it impacts
their business.
And if at all there is an
incident and that is impacting,
they want to be able to very
quickly diagnose and identify
the root cause of the
issue so that they
can take the most
appropriate remedial actions
and resolve the issues
faster and fast as possible.
On the other hand,
what is also happening
is as you build and
scale your API programs,
there is a goldmine
of API data that
is being collected
on the back end.
And API management
platforms like Apigee
have a great
opportunity to leverage
this data to actually
help customers, one,
improve the availability
and performance of the APIs,
and number two, to also ensure
that the APIs are secure
and meet the compliance
requirements.
So across the
entire value chain,
all the way from
your target back
end to front end
consumers, there
is this large amount of
metadata that Apigee is also
collecting at the back end.
So if you look at the Apigee
API Management Platform today,
it is Google Cloud comprehensive
full lifecycle management
platform, which includes a
runtime layer, a mediation
engine, API analytics, and also
provides you a developer portal
and monetization capability.
But the way we are
leveraging the API data today
is by providing three
different kind of metrics
for three different personas.
So for somebody like
the product manager,
we provide developer
engagement metrics,
and for a business
persona, we are
looking at business
metrics such as revenue
generation, et cetera.
And for an operations
persona, today, we
have deeply integrated
monitoring capabilities.
What we are introducing today
is API Security Reporting,
which is a new added
functionality which is also
leveraging the same API data.
What we have seen in
most of our customers
is that, depending on the size
of the customer-- depending
on the nature of
their business--
they have either an ops person
looking into the security
attributes, or there is a SecOps
person dedicatedly looking
at the security attributes.
So this feature
essentially targets both
the current IT admin or
office persona and also
the SecOps persona.
So let's learn a little
bit about this new feature
that we just added.
What is API Security Reporting?
It provides deep insights
for operations teams
to basically do three
very important things.
One is to ensure
that all of the APIs
that are being developed
by the development teams
are adhering to the security
and compliance requirements.
Number two is to ensure
that the sensitive data
within the organization
is not abused
by internal or external users.
And number three is when
there is an incident,
it provides you the
capabilities to quickly
identify and diagnose
the root cause
and quickly take remedial
actions to solve it.
Let's get into each of these
functionalities in detail.
Security compliance
is essentially
a functionality that
addresses the design time
governance of the product.
It is about ensuring
that developers
who are the core power
users of our platform
are building APIs
that incorporate
all the policies required
by the compliance teams.
In many cases, we
have seen customers
who think that the APIs
that are being built
are by default adhering
to all the policies.
But only when something
breaks, they actually
realize that that's not really
happening on the field, right?
With this feature,
users can quickly
identify proxies that do not
adhere to traffic security
and extension
policy requirements,
and users will also be
able to very quickly review
what are the shared
flow configurations
and revisions for
each of those proxies.
And you can also
analyze which hosts,
which virtual
hosts and ports are
open to receiving
secure traffic,
as compared to unsecure traffic.
As we discussed earlier,
several enterprises
are today covering business
critical applications
through APIs.
So there is a lot
of sensitive data
that is actually
involved in these APIs.
For example, developer
information, trade sessions,
API keys--
all of these are
attributes that are
vulnerable to abuse from
internal and external users.
So with this new feature,
users can very closely
monitor who within
your organization
is actually accessing this
sensitive information,
and if there are any anomalies
in that access [INAUDIBLE]
you can discover or detect
those suspicious behavior.
Apigee by default also
provides ways for you
to extract information
outside of the platform
through management
APIs, and it becomes
extremely critical for your
operations teams to make sure--
to monitor those users who
are actually extracting
this data out of the platform.
So on top of all the
logging capabilities
that Apigee offers
today, data protection
is one additional
feature that helps
you to look at all
the user activity that
is happening inside your ops.
And the third capability
that we've got
is precision diagnosis.
Precision diagnosis essentially
address the runtime governance
with software security.
It gives you the insights into
what percentage of traffic
is secure versus nonsecure,
and when there is a security
incident, you can
quickly analyze
which apps are causing
those security incidents
and which back end targets
are actually getting
affected because of that.
You can also identify
anomalies in traffic patterns,
identify the root causes
for those anomalies,
and basically take the most
appropriate remedial actions
to solve this.
What is happening
with this capability
is that a lot of
operations teams
find it very useful
in terms of overall
reducing their overall mean time
to diagnose an issue, and also
the mean time to take
remedial actions.
So with that, let's just take
a quick break from the slides
and actually go into the
product and take a quick demo.
So this is the
Apigee API Console,
and if you go to the Analyze
section on the left menu,
just below the API Monitoring,
which we launched last year,
there is API Security Reporting.
This is the new feature.
Go to the Overview page.
So there is a
functionality for users
to actually look at this from
four different timelines.
You can look at the last
one hour, the last one day,
seven days, and even 30 days.
So let's look at the
last seven days' data.
So what you see at
the first glance
is the northbound traffic.
This is the traffic that is
coming into the Apigee API
platform, and you can see across
different environments what
are the number of proxies
that are deployed.
What you see here
as active proxies
are the proxies that are
actually receiving traffic.
And 16 is essentially
the number of proxies
that have been deployed.
And against each of
these environments,
you can see the amount of
traffic that is coming in
and what is the
percentage change.
So if you kind of predict
that this kind of change
that you see in
this environment,
there's something very
alarming or it is uncommon,
then you can quickly look
at the runtime reports
and see what's actually
happening there.
We will see that just
in about a minute.
We will also see the
traffic for region.
This is especially
useful for customers
who have proxies deployed
across several regions,
and when there is traffic
coming from various regions.
And when there is a
security incident,
it will be very easy
for the ops person
to look at the abnormalities
in the specific region
and quickly drill
down into that region
and see what exactly
is happening on there.
And if you have logged
into this platform
as an org admin, what you will
also see is user activity.
And by the way this
feature is available only
for the org admins.
You can quickly see
who are the users that
are accessing the platform,
and this is for the time window
that we've selected here,
which is seven days.
You will see the
number of UI things,
and you will see the
number of API usage
and also see the
change in the activity,
and what are the
sensitive operations
that they are accessing.
Let's learn a little
bit about user activity.
So again, I come
to User Activity
and selecting the
last seven days' data.
So what you see here is
a list of all the users
that in this
particular org which
is selected who
have been accessing
the org for the last seven days.
And you can see here the
number of logins, number
of UI operations, and
APIs is essentially
the management APIs that
have been accessed by users
over this period of time.
And when there is a
change in activity,
you can see the
normal hits here,
and this is where
exactly you will
see the sensitive
operations of the user.
So what are
sensitive operations?
The way they have defined
sensitive operations
is when a user is
accessing information
that contains either
developer information, app
information, virtual hosts,
trace sessions, or custom
reports.
And let's say if there is
one particular user who
has accessed a lot
of sensitive data,
and if you feel
that the user is not
supposed to be
accessing that, you
can very quickly
contact that user
and take the most
appropriate action.
What we also have here
is the Compliance page.
This is the design
time governance aspect
that I was talking
about earlier.
So here, the first
thing that you can do
is look at the
various environments
and select the right environment
that you want to look in.
And then you will see the
list of all the proxies,
as well as their relevant
provision number against that.
And what you also see
here is the number
of policies that
have been configured
for each of these proxies.
These policies include traffic
policy, security policy,
as well as the extension policy.
What you will also
see is the number
of shared flows
that are configured
for each of the proxies,
and you will also
be able to see whether this
particular proxy has been
receiving secure traffic
HTTPS or if there's
unsecure traffic on non-HTTPS.
And let's click on
one of these and see
what additional information
you can see here.
So when you click on this,
on the right hand panel,
you will also see the
details of the policies that
have been configured
against these policies.
On the Shared Flows,
you will basically
see the list of all
the shared flows that
have been configured, and when
you select that shared flow,
you will also see
the policies that
are configured against this
particular shared flow.
And what we also have
here is the Target view.
And Target view
essentially will give you
information about that
particular [AUDIO OUT]
has received secure traffic
or if it's nonsecure traffic.
In several cases,
we have also seen
that customers have realized
that some of the targets
have been configured to
receive non-HTTPS traffic,
and after using
this feature enough,
they kind of very quickly
were able to change
the configurations to
ensure that it receives
only the secure traffic.
And the third component that I
want to talk about is runtime.
This is the runtime
governance aspect.
And just like compliance, you
can also select the environment
that you want to look at.
You can change
the timeline here.
And you can also select regions,
if you have multi regions,
and look at the
traffic that is flowing
into each of these proxies.
So what you see here is the
traffic over the selected
period of time and
the percentage change,
and what percentage is
HTTPS versus non-HTTPS.
You will also be
able to quickly see
what other aspects are
accessing this proxy,
and if there is
any of [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's take a
situation and understand
this a little better.
If there is a high
percentage change
in the traffic that is
coming to a particular proxy,
and [INAUDIBLE] I add an ops
person, I add a SecOps person.
I understand that this is
something that is not supposed
to happen, and that that is
coming mostly from a nonsecure
forward, then I
will be very quickly
able to understand which
app is causing the traffic.
And once I know that,
I'll be able to take
the most remedial actions.
And to mitigate the
damage that is happening,
I can also look at which target
is actually being affected
because of the [INAUDIBLE].
So this kind of significantly
reduces the overall time
to understand what
is going wrong
with that particular proxy, and
take the most remedial action.
So that is all about
the new security
reporting feature
that we launched.
If you have any
further questions,
please feel free
to reach out to us.
And if you are not an
Apigee Edge customer,
please do download the free
trial and start using this.
Thank you so much for joining
us, and have a nice afternoon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]